es momento de hablar de economía en
france 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero luís méndez luis
bienvenido iniciamos con la preocupación
existente por un aumento en la deuda en
países de bajos ingresos es una
situación que se desprende del informe
emitido por el banco mundial y que
revela el crecimiento de la deuda de más
de 70 países en 12% empujando el monto
total un récord de 860 mil millones de
dólares de acuerdo con el documento esta
es la consecuencia de la pandemia de
kobe 19 debido a que muchos gobiernos
respondieron en la situación con paquete
de estímulo fiscal monetario financiero
masivo pero mientras estas medidas
estaban orientadas a abordar la
emergencia sanitaria entre otras cosas y
llevar a los países al camino de la
recuperación se generó una presión sobre
la deuda de muchas naciones donde
incluso antes de la pandemia muchas de
éstas se encontraban en situación
vulnerable los niveles sostenibles de
deuda son vitales para la recuperación
económica y la reducción de la pobreza
así lo indicó david malpass presidente
del banco mundial en el informe en este
sentido y en el marco de los encuentros
anuales entre el fondo monetario
internacional y el banco mundial
kristalina georgieva alertó sobre la
necesidad de una acción coordinada para
comenzar a detener y revertir el
incremento de estados frágiles es
bastante grave vamos ahora con el precio
del petróleo que se incrementó de este
lunes así es porque logró establecerse
en máximos históricos no vistos en
varios años el petróleo se mantuvo por
encima de los 80 dólares el brent
alcanzó el máximo de tres años al
ubicarse en 84 dólares con 38 centavos
mientras que el gas texas cerró en 81
dólares dólares con 72 centavos esta
situación se presenta básicamente por
una fuerte demanda y la escasez de
suministros también vale recordar que la
oferta mundial del crudo se ha visto
afectada por la decisión de la opep en
conjunto con otros productores de
petróleo de no aumentar la producción
para estabilizar los precios
y ahora pasamos a argentina porque ese
país va a limitar la exportación de maíz
por lo que resta de la temporada así lo
anunció el ministerio de agricultura
luego de que la nación alcanzase las
38,5 millones de toneladas exportadas
disponibles para la campaña no obstante
eso no significa que no habrá más
exportación de maíz procedente de la
nación sudamericana sino que el gobierno
habilitará a aquellas que están
confirmadas para un lapso de 30 días lo
que significa que serán autorizadas las
empresas que tengan el grano comprado y
un barco asignado en argentina la
temporada de cosecha de maíz comienza en
febrero y termina en julio por lo que el
límite de exportación es variable y
depende de la cantidad de maíz cosechado
y hablamos ahora de los premios nobel de
economía el reconocimiento recayó en
tres académicos premiados por sus
experimentos desarrollados en
situaciones de la vida real uno de ellos
fue el canadiense de vícar quien nació
en 1956 y fue reconocido por su
contribución empírica sobre la economía
del trabajo también fueron premiados
joshua and grease líquido y pensé que
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo carr
recibir su premio
mauer story en el estudio del salario
mínimo creo que lo que realmente salió
de eso contrario a lo que todos piensan
no es que debamos aumentar el salario
mínimo sino más bien el enfoque sobre
una forma diferente de pensar como los
salarios establecen
a wilster ser bueno vamos ahora a ver
que hay preocupación en la línea aérea
southwest sí porque más de 1.900 vuelos
programados durante el fin de semana
fueron cancelados por esta situación la
empresa ha culpado al clima y algunos
problemas que ha presentado el tráfico
aéreo en florida de acuerdo con la
agencia de noticias reuters la aerolínea
había cancelado mil 124 vuelos o el 30
por ciento de su operación el día
domingo y previamente el sábado dejaron
de salir otros 800 vuelos el conflicto
provocó que las acciones de la compañía
cayeran alrededor de un 4% continuamos
con los indicadores de la jornada
cierres a la baja en el mercado
estadounidense de marcados por el
nerviosismo de los inversionistas
previos la temporada de informes de
ganancias del tercer trimestre por otro
lado en europa también hubo cierres
mixtos la jornada marcada por
movimientos estrechos y presionados por
los precios del petróleo en japón acaba
de abrir el mercado con caídas en su
principal bolsa en américa latina'
contrario a lo ocurrido en eeuu hubo
cierres víctor pero hay expectativa en
torno a la temporada de resultados
trimestrales y por último tenemos la
cifra al día y tiene que ver en este
caso con la recaudación de ecuador que
fue de 10 mil 390 millones de dólares
entre enero y septiembre del presente
año una cifra que es mil 18 millones más
que el mismo período del año anterior
listas muchas gracias por esta
ampliación a ustedes por su sintonía
pueden continuar con nosotros en france
24 punto com
[Música]